hey youtubers is Charlie Happy New Year
so this is going to be my Sherlock
special video this is really like a
series for special it meant to tell the
story of how Moriarty survived or did
not survive basically just to explain
the end of what happened at Series three
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
Sherlock the abominable bride now just
to explain what's going on if you
haven't seen Sherlock before at the end
of series three the Moriarty character
seemingly came back from the dead the
twist of this episode is that Sherlock
goes into his mind Palace and the mind
Palace just happens to be during the
original timeline of the Conan Doyle
stories while is in the mind palace he
uses this ricoletti unsolved case to
find out how Moriarty might have been
able to come back so it wraps up series
three tees up series four then they're
making a regular series four there'll be
three regular episodes each 90 minutes
just like there normally are but they
won't air till next year so it'll be
another full year before we get more but
what I'm going to do is my top 10 WTF
moments and then I'll do a bunch of
Easter eggs now because Sherlock
episodes are 90 minutes long and they
take so much longer to write the scripts
they are crammed with Easter eggs from
the Conan Doyle stories but they also
draw from all things Sherlock so like
there's stuff from the 1970s movie this
story the overarching ricoletti story
the abominable bride is taken from
unpublished Sherlock Holmes stories so
any Sherlock Holmes story that's ever
been told in a book on screen is fair
game for them to pull from so top 10 WTF
starting with number 1 Sherlock and
Watson meeting for the first time in
full period a lot of these retreads of
the original time that they met and as
Sherlock explains later when he wakes up
on the plane sometimes Sherlock reads
through Watson's stories of their
adventures to help him work through new
problems so Sherlock in the mine Palace
is rereading through their entire
history together all their adventures to
try and figure out this Moriarty problem
number 9 WTF marry in the flashbacks
every bit as clever as she is in present
day I love the way they play with
flashback marry 2 and they kind of tee
it like the first time you see her they
T up that Watson is kind of neglectful
which is a theme that runs across the
episode men taking advantage of or
mistreating women number 8 WTF meet the
abominable bride so we get the tee up
they have this amazing cinematography
where like you shoot from the room
room ends up being on the crime scene
this goes to show you what you can do
when you spend this much time shooting
an episode now of course is bad because
you don't get as much Sherlock but it
looks so much more amazing shotgun
wedding for the win
of course we find out later in the
episode that she faked her death using
two different guns in a fake body on the
number 7 WTF meet male Molly Hooper it's
amazing what you have to do to get head
in a man's world there's a lot going on
in the scene but I think largely it's
just meant to serve the theme of women
being underserved in such a patriarchy
is especially 19th century Great Britain
but when you think about it this is all
Sherlock imagining all these things so
he's actually gender-bending Molly
Hooper and kind of weaves her into this
story so it seems like he is aware that
he is mistreating her in modern day like
everything that's happening inside this
mind Palace is all of his own constructs
is doing that consciously so maybe when
she shows up in series 4 modern-day
Molly Hooper he'll treat her a lot nicer
but we'll see if he learns anything from
this on to number 6 WTF meet fat Mycroft
now this is actually much closer to the
original depiction of the character like
if you look at this picture here this is
what Conan Doyle's version of the
character looked like Mycroft much more
clever than Sherlock and I think it's
really telling of how Sherlock thinks
very little of himself that mind
polished Sherlock makes fun of mine
palace Mycroft
by telling him he's getting fatter and
fatter that's the only comeback that he
has when Mycroft makes fun of Sherlock
for being slow which means in no
uncertain terms
Sherlock really has zero self-esteem
which does seem connected to the fact
that he's such a drug addict so really
when Mycroft is making fun of Sherlock
when everyone inside the mine Palace is
making furniture like even Mary makes
fun of Sherlock inside the mind Palace
Sherlock is really making fun of himself
but I got to say though fact Mycroft is
just so funny just the bed about how
soon he's going to die
I've got a bet to win and he just you
just starts grabbing plum-pudding
on the number 5 WTF meet Lady Carmichael
and they try to save her husband but he
winds up dying at the hands of the
abominable bride too later we find out
after Sherlock figures it out in his
mind palace
we learned that janine is this
abominable bride and that the other
abominable bride is played by Molly
Hooper which i think is kind of funny is
really Sherlock projecting his own
thoughts onto the case so there may have
been multiple abominable brides at that
scene in that case for the way they're
telling the story it was actually lady
Carmichael who dressed up as the bride
to kill her husband but I love the way
they take present-day characters and
weave them into that historical
narrative like oh we've been mistreating
them you know through series 1 to series
3 on the number 4 WTF the invisible army
explained the interesting thing about
this is that Mycroft had worked it out
in his head when they went to see him
for the first time meaning that Sherlock
had already worked it out but I need you
to do the legwork so we go through the
paces but then we find out that Mary has
sent a telegram to Sherlock she figured
it out before they did so they show up
at all the masks come off in its
womankind like all of womankind is this
invisible army taking the mantle of the
bride to help any woman in need so
basically the abominable bride is kind
of like the mantle of the bat it's kind
of a Batman thing one goes down another
picks up the symbol of the number 3 WTF
Sherlock versus Moriarty round 1 it was
around the time I saw him reach for the
syringe and then the ghostly voice of
Moriarty spoke that I thought that we
might be viewing things in some sort of
dream state I didn't think it was the
mind Palace right away but the old timey
mind palace with the the scraps of paper
that was that was so amazing so it's
like he's in his mind palace but inside
the mind Palace he is also inside the
mind palace he's like two levels of
Inception down we have to go deeper
which he does later when he goes to the
Reichenbach Falls when he has like the
final confrontation with Moriarty but on
a number two WTF did you make a list so
we hear that the first time and it
sounds kind of weird because it's fat
Mycroft saying it and they haven't
revealed that Sherlock is in present day
just having a mind Palace episode
because of a drug cocktail that he took
so you wake up in present day and you're
like WTF we find out that it's been five
minutes since the end of series 3 and
then we jump forward in time like here
he goes back into the mine palace a
couple times throughout this as he
finally figures out that Moriarty did
die and now I know what he's going to do
next but I'll say my number one WTF is
that end credits tag where it goes back
to the mine palace and they talk about
the case being called the abominable
bride like they think of different names
I hope you'll note it's one of my very
few failures Watson the weird thing
about this scene in the way it's
anachronistic is that it's almost
positing you know just for a couple
seconds that the old timey mine pal
Sherlock was actually imagining all the
present-day stuff so you're meant to
think who is imagining who like is this
the version of Sherlock that's mind
Palace a future Sherlock or is it future
Sherlock mind palace in old timey
Sherlock huge WTF that's going to have
you run in the circles for a little
while but just you know classic Moffat
doctor who techniques especially like
the doctor inside the confession died on
the way that that plays with time and
perception of reality so let me know in
the comments what's your favorite moment
from this episode and where would you
rank this on all the Sherlock episodes
so far I'll say right now this isn't my
favorite but it's tied for first with
his last foul and then like my next
favorite after that is empty hearse
Miley's favorite is still Hound of
Baskerville I feel like that's the
weakest episode of Sherlock so far
just a reminder series 4 won't be coming
till 2017 but it will premiere like this
time next year you will be able to see
Martin Freeman during Captain America
Civil War in may and then I think it's
November for Doctor Strange in Benedict
Cumberbatch but just to talk about a
couple of the Easter eggs the 7%
solution is actually a story by Nicholas
Meyer it's also the relative amount of
cocaine when he takes a dosage like it's
a syringe that's only 7 percent cocaine
that that's like the strength of
solution that he takes the moment when
they're at Lady Carmichael's mansion
waiting for the ghost to show for the
first time that also happened during the
speckled band' that you know they have
like this stakeout moment where they
just sit and talk to each other the five
orange pips was an actual story by Conan
Doyle at the beginning of the episode
when Watson's like maybe it's secret
twins and Sherlock's like it's never
twins Watson it actually was twins
during sine of three and when I said
that this episode as a whole was based
on the unpublished stories someone in
real life found a bunch of Conan Doyle
unpublished Sherlock stories in an attic
somewhere after like 80 years of being
lost but if you guys spotted any other
Easter eggs that I didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments there were a lot of references
to the normal Sherlock episodes like
series one two three and I think there
were a couple lines of dialogue whenever
they first walked into 221b Baker Street
from the 1970 movie but why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my Sherlock playlist with
like all the Sherlock videos that I've
ever done I think I only did up to
series two I don't think I did series
one videos and you can click here for my
10 Crais
it's Star Wars Episode seven theories
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight